one name that certainly is an it name
when it comes to defining Oscar elegance
Versace M Gianni Versace put the same
style and elegance that goes into the
gallons into his legendary mansion of
Palace in Miami
it's a massive opulent estate and it's
been turned into one of the riskiest
hotels in the world and a Carly she'll
got a private tour
in South Beach's villa-casa casuarina 10
bedrooms 11 bath set out in 23 thousand
square feet of Mediterranean decadence
this is the villa suite and this
actually was Gianni Versace is smooth um
okay this is the biggest bed I've ever
seen in my life and what celebrities
have stayed here oh there's been all
sorts this is where Kim Kardashian
stayed the Kardashians actually rented
out the entire hotel once Scott having a
rowdy moment with fans outside they hung
out in it I think this is where they all
hung out you see them all thrown thrown
across the bed chit chit chatting and
hanging out the Suites run from a
thousand to forty two hundred dollars a
night most say worth every penny
hand-painted murals on nearly every wall
intricate mosaics on the floor gold on
the fixtures on the beds in the pool
Kylie Jenner swam in that fifty four
foot beauty and so did the beads
I hope Justin Bieber was clothed um
partially Justin stated the Venus room
at three thousand per night now is
Justin a well behaved guests in here
with any crazy room service orders or
anything like well he kept our room
service busy around the clock
Jenny entertained his a-list pals here
such as Liz Taylor Elton John sly but in
1997 Versace was murdered on the
doorstep of his palace it's quite a lot
of people who believe in the
supernatural who feel that he literally
still is here it's spirit and that's
been oh they've claimed they've seen
spirits and they've gone to certain
rooms and strange doors open and close
and things of that nature
thank you this action